voici 4 milliard le nouveau jouet idéal
qui annule et tient votre chat occupez
vous pouvez maintenant commander votre
bac 4 millions au prix spécial télé 2 19
dollars 99
mais attendez ap maintenant et vous
obtiendrez un deuxième qasmi en gratuit
ne paient que des frais séparer de
manutention et de livraison ces frais de
manutention et livraison font monter le
prix spécial télé de 80 pour ça il passe
de 19 dollars 99 1 35 $ 80 pour
commander quatre l'autre problème c'est
que le site de 4me en est loin d'être
clair la première chose qu'on vous
demande c'est de numéro de votre carte
de crédit vous cliquer sur ce bouton
rouge on vous facture déjà vos 2 4
milliard on vous présente ensuite ce
bouton vert pour confirmer la commande
croyait pas du tout à chaque clic sur ce
bouton on facture
deux autres quatre semaines sur votre
carte pas facile de comprendre qu'il
faut cliquer sur ce bouton pour mettre
fin à la commande nous avons dû payer 71
dollars 78 ne devenez surtout pas la
souris victimes de ces chats prédateurs